loneliness is a problem in modern Japan
in fact there are companies throughout
Japan that provide fake families for
people who are lonely I'm not making
this up and I thought why don't I get a
fake family while I'm here in Tokyo I
have now been in Japan for two days and
I am very lonely I have two children who
show me very little respect
and I have a wife who is tired of my
jokes my father and I get along pretty
well but I honestly think I could do
better like a new father that would
apologize for some things that happened
between us in the 1970s specifically
when he lost his temper in the kitchen
because I spilled a bowl of creamed corn
and then he didn't let me watch The Love
Boat that night and I'm told it was a
very good episode yeah he Arthur was on
it from the Golden Girls
she's a divorcee who meets a man who
she's interested in it turns out that
he's a scam artist and he's played by
Harvey Korman quick question
the wife what are the boundaries with
this that I choose normal Oh
hugging shake the hands but no kissing
so just like my current marriage white
she looks very beautiful thank you may I
ask how old she is
yeah judge Oh 48 okay it is close to my
own age
so this is a no yes I'm from Los Angeles
and a man my age is required by law to
marry a woman who's 25 this is a
possible son how old is he well 35 I
don't have us I could not have a son
who's 35
no he's too old to be my son and also
I'm worried my fake son is gonna run
away with my fake wife who is this I
mean how old is she June that's very
good I think she has a good sense of
humor do you have any father candidates
oh my god I feel like I've already
disappointed him
oh hey wait a minute now we're talking
look at him he looks Pleasant good guy
took the gum cornichons mr. users I like
that my father my wife and my daughter
yes and they will be my family while I'm
in Japan mmm
if I'm really enjoying my fake family
what's the maximum amount of time I can
retain their services some three years I
could have them for three years you
don't need to check with her she's 12 my
current family won't give me three more
years also one more question is it
possible for me to rent someone who
could pretend to be a bully it was mean
to me in high school and I can beat the
[ __ ] out of her sewing it was
I bow to you I honor you okay I swear to
god this is real I left family romance
about an hour and 20 minutes ago I am
back in my hotel room in Tokyo and I
have a family like daughter I am now
your father and she thinks some of the
coolest dad in the world
another thing that's important to me is
that I am very funny when I tell a joke
I would like it if you all really
laughed and thought it was funny could
you explain to them could you do that
could you laugh if I tell a joke okay
let me ask you a question
- guys like ramen thumb is key not me I
like my men cooked these seven
collateral
[Laughter]
so much better
[Applause]
everything's a joke okay I'm worried now
that if I tell her oh I just came back
from the doctor and I only have a year
to live
[Laughter]
dad nice to meet you how are you sliding
down maybe you could begin by
apologizing just say I was wrong to yell
at you in the 70s try I was wrong when
the seven things you were wrong in the
70s right yeah in 1978 when I spilled
the creamed corn you say I was wrong I
apologize I'm sorry about the creamed
corn we mean a lot to me if you said I
liked you more than your brothers liked
you more than your brothers yes I'm the
best one right yes of course you were my
favorite song
[Applause]
they'll hug you more than a pump my real
father you guys want to go see Tokyo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]